yeah he was in itu unfortunately I
didn't have the best of experiences he
had congenital pneumonia so he had fluid
in his lungs and I had to have a
C-section so I was a bit paranoid
because I was working a lot of hours and
as I got bigger I didn't feel him move
as much the hospital decided to induce
me early but he was John the 14th of
November but they were like no we need
to induce you and my blood pressure kept
going up as well so a bit of a traumatic
experience for me to be honest obviously
not planning for a C-section I was like
I'm gonna do this naturally I want to
push and all the rest of it but it's not
down to you it's down to your body and
what your body is capable of doing and
you know it's not something that I was
really upset about it and he was in by
to you for a week and that week for me
was hell I was in a really dark place